well as we mentioned earlier Russia and
Belarus have begun two weeks of Air
Force military drills in the two
countries have held joint exercises in
the past years Russia began its
offensive in Ukraine well this time the
Belarusian defense Ministry says the
Tactical flight exercises are defensive
in nature now there are concerns Moscow
may be pushing Minsk to join the war in
Ukraine
there's been an alarm about a buildup of
Russian troops in Belarus and Mercury
activity in the country in recent weeks
Moscow had used its neighbor as a
springboard to launch attacks on Ukraine
almost a year ago
and Hashem is life for us again in
Moscow so Ali again once again what a
Russian officials saying about why
they're conducting these joint Air Force
drills with Belarus what's the goal
well tell me what's being said here in
Moscow is that these drills are for
operational compatibility so um just a
few weeks after President Putin's visit
to Belarus to Minsk by the end at the
end of
December and now we see that the Russian
Aerospace Force going to Belarus and
conducting this drills there now with
respect to the details of these drills
they're going to be more technical as
you mentioned more on supplies patrols
however there are many fears that or
concerns that these are just it's just
the beginning before the uh the the the
conducting of the training of the
Belarus Pilots which was agreed on in
the uh and the President Putin's visit
during President Putin's visit to
Belarus last month it was agreed that
Russia will start training the Belarus
pilots on using the sohoi planes for and
that will be carrying
unconventional weapons so this is the
issue that maybe some people are
concerned over there's another issue
that's also being taken into
consideration that these uh drills are
also Shifting the attention of inside
Ukraine from the borders with Russia to
the borders with Belarus and this will
cause that the the Ukrainian authorities
or the Ukrainian government will also
move forces towards the the north just
to take into consideration that there
there might be any kind of shift on the
on the front so this is in general
what's being said with respect to the uh
to the drills however this is expected
to continue and this is not the first
drill that goes between the Russians and
the Belarus government or the Belarus
Army this is continuing but this is the
first time since two years that the
Belarus Air Force and the Russian Air
Force are conducting uh kind of joint
drills together and it it's really
significant that it's taking place at
the time of the War uh in Ukraine
all right we'll leave it there thanks so
much Ali Hashem let's continue this
though with Natasha Butler she joins us
now live from Kiev so no doubt a
different perspective there in Cuba they
worried that these joint exercises are
preparations for another operation from
the north
but look any activity on the Bella
Russian border is of course going to be
of concern to authorities in Keys
they've been watching now over the past
few weeks this uh build up of Russian
forces and better Russian forces on that
border more military hardware coming in
the two sides carrying out a number of
military exercises the latest these air
exercises that are supposed to last for
two weeks so of course that is a concern
and even though the defense minister in
Belarus says these are just defensive
exercises that's enough to worry
officials in Ukraine because of course
they know that it was from uh territory
in Belarus that Russia launched its
offensive in February uh last year even
though Belarus and its forces weren't
directly involved they know that they
have to be careful and take every
precaution necessary it's why the
Ukrainian president of Vladimir
zielinski just last week said that
Ukrainian forces along that border must
be bolstered we know that they've really
been building fortifications for some
time now to be ready and prepared all
along that border there are those some
intelligence experts we the Pentagon for
example last week who have said that
they don't necessarily expect any new
offensive from the northern Board of
Ukraine over the belarussian Border
anytime soon however what they do say is
this could be a tactic by the Russians
to try and distract Ukraine and try and
lure some Ukrainian forces away from
fighting in the East up to the north
all right and that's Natasha Butler for
us from Kiev